- Tshooo
- Bee-boop bee-boop bee-boop.
- Space.
(chiming music)
If you put "space" in front
of anything, and that's
a better version of that.
- I'm scared of space.
- If I went to space, I'd
be the coolest thing ever.
- Can you taste in space?
- Does anything work in space?
- (laughs)
- Certified space technology,
you know, so it's legit.
- This is like a prop ice cream sandwich.
- Whoah, that is so cool,
but also I'm terrified.
- Whoah (laughs)
(cracks loudly)
- (laughs)
- Aw
- That was like biting into a brick.
- Actually this is delicious.
- It just tastes like a really dry Oreo.
- It is not an ice cream
sandwich, 'cause that's a lie.
- I'm fine with that.
- I'm fine with that too.
- Here's something to remind you of home,
but it's gonna taste completely different.
- It's like a brick.
- It feels like ramen.
- This doesn't look like food.
- Oh it does smell like mint
chocolate chip ice cream.
- I think it smells like plastic
pretending to be ice cream.
- It's like dried marshmallows.
- Not the worst.
- The flavor's so good, but
the texture's so bad for me.
- I almost feel like I wanna put that
on top of some ice cream.
- Yeah.
- If I was in space, I would eat this and
believe it's ice cream.
- What is this?
- Whoah.
- It's like drugs.
- This is like freeze-dried
Dippin' Dots I think,
and this is amazing.
- Neapolitan ice cream,
that's your favorite
two flavors of ice cream
and then strawberry.
- Look at these little pellets.
- They're so cute.
- These little ice cream poops.
- Oh no, oh now.
- Oh, gaw.
- Freeze dried Dippin' Dots, love it.
- It tastes like Tums.
- It's like if Neapolitan
ice cream was like expired.
- Cool concept, not into that flavor.
- The flavor, yeah.
- I bet if you ate just
a diet of astronaut food,
you would feel (mumbles).
- I did like my favorite
was ice cream sandwich.
- I like that ice cream
sandwich, I would have that,
like, here.
- On a daily basis.
- But also like who are we kidding,
like we de-funded NASA
and we don't send anyone
to space anymore, so the dream is dead!
- That's messed up.
- It's just so sad what's
happening over there.
- Oh yeah.
You don't know the half of it.